Pippa Middleton's bundle of joy has
arrived it's wonderful the 35 year old
socialite gave birth to her first child
with husband James Matthews they seemed
very well matched and certainly very
very happy together the two who tied the
knot in May 2017 announced they were
expecting in June just days before Pippa
sister Kate Middleton gave birth to her
third child with husband Prince William
[Applause]
HIPPA hasn't let pregnancy slower down
one bit despite being nine months
pregnant Kate's younger sister attended
the second royal wedding of the year
princess
Eugenie's October 12th nuptials to Jack
Brooks Fame she looked gorgeous in
head-to-toe emerald green proudly
showing off her pregnancy in a
long-sleeved denver amelia Wixted dress
that hugged her baby bump the new mom
completed her chic look with a matching
fascinator black pumps and Pippa small
jewelry I says it's patterning Pippa
wasn't the only expectant mother at the
royal event
Megan Markel is also pregnant with her
first child with Prince Harry according
to multiple reports the Duke and Duchess
shared the exciting news with the royal
family at Eugenie's wedding before going
public with the announcement three days
later
this means Megan Markel Kate Middleton
and her little sister Pippa will all
have kiddos around the same age it
doesn't get much sweeter than that there
is no doubt the sisters are hugely close
we have a very normal Cicely
relationship but we're very close and
you know we support each other and get
each other's opinion something Pippa has
been the definition of fitness goals
throughout her entire pregnancy she was
snapped out and about in London late
last month wearing a warm blue coat
printed Kate Spade dress and white
sneakers there is you know a lot of
pressure I get in London just my
day-to-day routine Pippa had reportedly
just finished a day of heavy fitness
class despite her then quickly
approaching October due date there's so
much I'd love to achieve
and I still want to keep up the sport
and health side of things cuz that's
really important to me and the 35 year
old has been blogging about her workout
throughout her pregnancy journey for UK
website Waitrose in one column Pippa
revealed that she continued to embrace
more inspired workouts throughout
pregnancy adding quote it's excellent
for pregnant woman in all trimesters as
you mostly rely on your body weight so
it means little impact for your joints
and is generally low risk she also
opened up about how much she enjoyed
swimming as a pregnancy workout
describing the wonderful feeling of
weightlessness
[Music]